the chicago bears have turned it around
in recent weeks and it all goes back to
the bye week when they had lost to the
minnesota vikings nick foles suffered an
injury late in the game mitchell
trubisky due to that injury initially
got back onto the field after being
benched in week three the last three
weeks two of the games wins they have
done very very well and
relative to how they were it's not like
they're all of a sudden kansas city
chiefs chris but they are better than
they were they were sluggish they were
ineffective for so long i spoke to matt
naggy the coach of the bears after the
game and he identified three tangible
factors for why they're better now one
when they went to the bye week they made
some moves on the offensive line and
it's settled down they've had
consistency on the offensive line which
is what you need to even begin to have
an effective and functional offense you
need an offensive line that is the same
five guys
and they play well and they play
together and that helps open up running
lanes and buy time for the quarterback
second
getting under center has been a factor
and that's something you've been
pointing out now i asked coach negge
point blank if the comments from coach
dungey when
we had the bears packers game a few
weeks ago and dungey worked it with uh
with mike tarico whether that was a
factor and and he laughed and he said no
that was something we've been trying to
do all the way back to training camp it
just hadn't happened but that offense
calls for shotgun 88 of the time 88
percent of the time right so they've
changed it and it's effective and now
they're well wait wait wait hold on but
what are you what were you what are you
trying like you like hey guy don't put
your hand there yet we're not trying to
go underneath the center yet you just do
it it's not that but okay well but my
point is it was it was part of the plan
back to training okay i know they just
woke up one day and said hey coach dungy
said we should go under center let's go
under center it's been part of the the
the intentional deliberate effort this
year to evolve the offense okay you know
they they hit some rough spots early and
now they've gotten back to it and the
concern is chris and and i think this is
a viable concern
to stay ahead of their own tendencies
that they're now setting with this
different look to the offense because at
some point there's enough film somebody
cracks the code somebody figures out how
to stop this switcheroo that the bears
have pulled so neggy said one of the
challenges is basically self-scout
themselves he didn't say that i wish he
had so they they're ready for when
defenses adjust to what they're doing
now yeah well listen i mean he's right i
i it's amazing what they're doing right
now it really is the transformation
they've made the last three weeks even
the loss to the detroit lions the
offense was great they weren't the
problems the defense you know so there's
a lot to that you know and and listen i
mean matt nagy you know again i
challenge the oh we wanted to get
underneath the center no just get under
the center you know do it you know and
then the self scouting that part that is
another one where i'd go
hey
well yeah i it's like they've
listened to my podcast i mean matt casey
producer can tell you these are things
i've been saying they're one of the
easiest teams to scout in all of
football the first 12 weeks of the year
they're so predictable you know exactly
what they're going to do there is
nothing to it you know the fact that
they have at least the threat of the
power run game and the bootleg as you
know we see a lot of teams in football
who'd live by that you know formula
right now in the nfl and it's very
successful i mean the team they're
playing yesterday the minnesota vikings
that's all they do you don't even
necessarily need to run the ball that
well
and play action and bootleg still have
an effect and that to me that's the
biggest thing more than anything here is
it's like the bears coaches finally
looked at their team and said
hey i'm going to stop making you guys
fit what i want to do and i'm actually
going to try to fit to what you guys are
good at and they've started to do that
to me that's been the biggest change
more than anything
and it's awesome to see and if their
offense can play like this you know
i mean i like their chances they're to
me when their offense is playing like
this i think they're better than the
cardinals i think they're a better
football team i'd take them in a
head-to-head matchup right now over
arizona i really would with their
defense and they're running the ball
that way i like their chances and i
think there's a really good chance they
do sneak in the playoffs here
and next week it's arizona hosting the
49ers whose home away from home is
arizona kind of a strange that really
parked there so yeah and the cardinals
have
the rams who you back who are you taking
there who are you taking
i think the bears make it i see that 27
possibility i think the bears i think
the bears make it uh i think they do i
think so too and the the fact that the i
mean i don't know if it'll affect either
but the rams losing yesterday
that pretty much assures that they're
like right they're gonna want to play
that week 17 game i don't know maybe
they maybe the rams end up in a
meaningless week 17 game where that that
saves them that could save arizona
i've been peaking ahead to week 17 from
time to time i can't make any sense of
who's going to be playing to win who's
not going to care who's going to be
they fall down right a spot in the
playoff tree to get a better match up in
the wild card round which i don't like
in general but
i can understand in some years where
especially this year where home field
advantage doesn't mean as much
maybe you'd be tempted to do it the last
reason the bear's offense has improved
is mitchell trubisky and
the benching of trubisky
in week three may have been the best
thing that's happened to him in his
entire career because nagi said he's
different now at practice he's more
confident he's more assertive he's
commanding the offense
and it shows week in and week out and
also you're throwing that ability to run
the ball that's why i picked the bears
to beat the vikings i'd seen that movie
before when the vikings had a decent
pass rush they couldn't handle
trubisky's running they definitely
couldn't handle it yesterday they
couldn't handle the offense yesterday
the vikings couldn't stop anything
yesterday that the chicago bears threw
at them and it still came down to a
fluky hail mary that almost was caught
you go back and watch that yeah it
almost caught by justin jefferson
definitely and it looked like there was
a blatant face mask of the guy who was
in position to try to catch the ball too
but hey they don't throw penalty flags
on hail mary's except when it's the
viking
defense which we saw last week right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports